[Musica]
dic i colori potrei fare uno slide
musiche colle o disponibili tra se
proprio l'imbarazzo della scelta
anche se un po incasinato questo
cassetto ma vabbè saviola e anche se si
illumina al buio con i glitter farò un
super mega flavi rainbow con tutti
michelori di colla ma dove sono gli
ingredienti in questa colla idea ci farò
un bel online
purtroppo solo questo però dai
proviamoci
mancano gioco dove lo faccio adesso
[Musica]
allora questo per il primo colore il
rosa questo per i blu
questo per il giallo petto per mischiare
tutti i colori oppure per altri tre
colori asti ci sta tutto qua creta per
altri quattro colori giganti a direi che
ora sono opposto con le ciotole no non
c'è mia scoprire se ora nome lì non c'è
nessuno neanche qui non c'è nessuna
ciotola trovarlo ho trovato questo
contenitore è un pezzo di carta posso
usare il contenitore per conservare lo
slime che farò sulla carta ma sono un
genio
iniziamo con la colla credo basti manca
qualcosa ma mi sono dimenticata la
spatola che colore di spatola potrà
insegnare per oggi aspetta le spatole
giganti tiri che le prendo tutte vediamo
quale vi può servire alla loro spatola
con un coccio di susa stato ripristinato
zappa non mi sembra il caso
ok non ho la spatola ma ho sempre dito
[Musica]
cosa c'è il marino devo dire qualcosa
sto sbagliando già ok ho letto nel e
colle la spatola né spatole
qualcos'altro casi le decorazioni
pallini glitter manca tutto ok andiamo a
sceglierle ecco qua un po di decorazioni
un po di glitter ma non sono mica le
uniche vi amo e il cassetto delle
meraviglie wow palline glitter pigmenti
quali sergo iter altri 20 preghiamo
tutto ok direi che questi possono
bastare come decorazioni
non so cosa metterlo che dici marino
mettiamo un pezzo di carta sì dai
mettiamo un bel pezzo di carta come
decorazione titolo di più mettiamo n'è
un altro questo lo facciamo tipo più
piccolino questo un pochettino più
grande dire che quasi perfetto come
decorazioni ottimo giriamo mi si incolla
un po però tanto una volta attivato sarà
perfetto ma prima dobbiamo attivarlo
adesso allora non ho ne è uscito fuori
con una soluzione per legge per abbiamo
niente aspetta
ho visto su youtube che si può
utilizzare il dentifricio però che
mobiliti silicio berlino che le 20 ora
scrivere a non mi sento sicuro io ci
provo book utilizziamo il dentifricio e
vediamo che cosa hai già fuori ma anche
questo bianco io speravo fosse blu
albero aveva un colore un pochettino
diverso cominciamo a girare attiviamo
attiviamo attiviamo attiviamo attiverà
motivi non si sta addensando che bello
ma ma la si sta sciogliendo o no sto
sciogliendo e come faccio adesso
[Musica]
buongiorno
un giorno un pos ogni giorno vorrei di
slam skifidol mega fluffy continuo tutta
la scatola tutto a nostro agio mia breve
grazie o no ma non funziona non si sta
attivando con il dentifricio
come devo fare si sta sciogliendo quello
di più invece di attivarsi ognuno o no
basta mi sono scocciato adesso vado
parlemo edicola uno slam
[Musica]
buongiorno vorrei un game skifidol mega
fluffy ok sono 31 e 50 57 57 78 dici che
il gettone della sala giochi lo accetta
che allora quinto di ci sono tre ore e
50 che bello grazie a riaprirli tutti
trovate i nuovi slime skifidol mega
floppy in edicola in una nuova formula
mega allungabile che non stecca mai ci
sono dei colori diversi
mi raccomando fate vi sempre dare il
magazine
in allegato e ora vediamo un po come
sono e proviamo a mischiare tutti colori
assieme così vediamo di che colore
diventa
diventate una sorta di giallo verdolino
multicolor degradé su vieni ti regalo
festa e festa ma non è caduta nei test
grazie in questa maniera ma anche un
pezzo di questo vi ricordo che potete
trovare i nuovissimi slime skippy dal
mega fluffy in edicola se vi è piaciuto
questo video mi raccomando lasciatemi
france e ora vi lasciamo a 436 est più
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
licata su quella che preferite v
realizzare ciò